MAX SALTONSTALL: Building
an infrastructure
has more options than ever,
but managing deployments
with automated systems
and doing it securely?
Join us as we talk with
Two Sigma about how
they made it happen on
this episode of Stack Chat.
Thanks for joining us, Nick.
Tell us a little
more about Two Sigma
and how you manage
your deployments.
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS: Sure,
thanks for having us.
At Two Sigma we combine data
science and technology, as well
as financial
expertise, and we use
that to develop
sophisticated trading models.
These help us uncover value
in the world's markets.
As you can imagine, this
requires the right balance
of allowing multiple
stakeholders and researchers
to iterate on research pretty
rapidly, while still protecting
authorization and
controlling our IP.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Can you
show us what that looks like?
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS:
Sure, so this
isn't an exact representation
of our specific environment,
but it's a good abstraction
that we can use as a baseline
to talk about from.
So we started out with just
some Super Admin identities,
and then we decided to extend
our on-premise existing
source of truth for identity,
which in our case is LDAP,
to Google Identity, and we
used Google Cloud Directory
Sync to do that.
Then we use identity and
access management policies
to restrict who can access
Google Cloud resources.
This includes things like
Google Cloud storage buckets,
compute instances, other
services, BigQuery,
a few others.
MAX SALTONSTALL: How do you
lock down the permissions
for these new resources?
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS: We create
a pretty granular identity
in access management
policy so we can limit
who has access to resources.
And we also heavily
restrict things
that we consider
privileged operations.
So for us, that's anything
that could impact the security
posture of a project, like
IAM changes or changes
to the virtual private
cloud structure,
Google Cloud Storage
bucket permissions,
or BigQuery data
set permissions.
We control those pretty heavily.
Further to that, only
Two Sigma employees
have access to our resources.
We don't share with
any external parties.
And we set up specific
role-based access controls
even within our organization,
such as only granting
the public cloud
engineering team
and the reliability
engineering team access
to manage Compute
Engine instances.
We mandated security keys and
10-minute session time outs
for our Super Admins.
As you can imagine, those
are very powerful accounts
and we want to protect
them accordingly.
We also took a step where we
blocked virtual machine images
from being shared
between projects,
because this was another control
for us to prevent exfiltration
of our data from potentially
a more secure production
environment to a development
environment that's
less locked down.
Finally, we use VPC Service
Controls, and specifically
the Secure Perimeters
product to protect
data in-location such as Google
Cloud Storage and BigQuery
at the API level.
These policies together let us
secure access to our resources,
and they're pretty easy
for us to edit and iterate
on as we implement
additional policies
or as we decide to change
our security model.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So that secures
the users and some of the data,
but what about the network?
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS: All
of our virtual machines
are launched in virtual
private cloud environments,
and this helps
keep them segmented
and segregated at
the network level.
We use organization
policies and firewall rules
to limit access from
anything outside of the VPC
to hitting those hosts.
Of course, we had
to connect the VPCs
to data sources in our
internal data centers
to enable research
workflows and modeling,
and we use private
interconnect to do that.
This communication also
enabled accessibility
to our internal
[? Cobras ?] infrastructure.
So we use that to handle
system authentication
and authorization at the
operating system layer
the same way we would on-prem.
It gives us a unified
authorization model.
To further lock things
down, in all of our VPCs
we removed the right
to the internet
so that no external
resources can
be accessed from inside of
the VPC by a compute instance.
In some very
specific projects we
also used Identiy-aware
Proxy, and this
helps us authorize a
subset of our researchers
to access specific isolated
resources in our GCP
organization in a controlled
and secure manner,
but still allowing them
a little more flexibility
in their workflows.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
It sounds like this
was a really iterative
process, as you lock down
different portions.
If you knew now everything
you learned throughout,
what would you do differently?
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS: We
created a lot of tech debt
through duplicating our efforts
in our early exploratory
initiatives.
So you can imagine we had a
bunch of different projects
that we'd set up individually.
Each of them had their
own IAM policies,
organization policies,
and private connectivity
configured.
We've gone through a lot
of different measures
for connectivity.
So we started out with public
peering, then we moved to VPN,
and finally private
interconnect.
But we duplicated
this infrastructure
across each of those
distinct projects
and this led to a lot of
complexity and management
overhead.
And as you can imagine,
as you add projects
this just increases
exponentially,
and we were kind of
tripping over ourselves.
So in hindsight, I think
at an earlier stage
if we'd decided to architect
for shared services a lot more,
using things like a shared
VPC, using policy inheritance,
all things that trickle down
from the organization level,
I think we would
have been in a better
position to build firm-wide
platforms that could be reused
by multiple teams and multiple
businesses much earlier
in the process.
And this would have saved us a
lot of effort and complexity,
and we would have
been able to iterate
even faster than we do now.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Thanks so
much for sharing your security
journey.
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS:
Our pleasure.
MAX SALTONSTALL: If you'd like
to learn more about setting up
IAM policies,
including setting them
at the organizational
level, check out
the link in the description.
Thanks for watching, and
make sure to subscribe
for more great Google
Cloud Platform content.
We'll see you next
time on Stack Chat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]